welcome to this video playing what's
this name tigerpaw from Brazil okay we
get what do we get sort of sort of
philidor set up this is one of the less
precise weights to play it but why
exactly I think it since there is some
nice g55 IDM 95 is it ticking I think
taking a 95 is the way to go 95 Bishop
g5 qui g5 this is I think the point yeah
here i have i have 96
I wonder why you playing this so quickly
okay 96 the problem there is nothing
else than taking anyway okay yeah well
the problem was taking at Bishop b6 we
can look at it afterwards okay should I
give the check here to provoke g6 maybe
check then drop back to eat too so that
or maybe G for you Queen g4 why not
double attacking e6 okay look the one
with the temple and we are loops looks
good and now Knight c3 probably
intending to play be four yeah but can
assist there isn't there some sort of
sacrifice like night b5 something like
that
probably no decisive no decisive thing I
can still play before an a4 a.m. be for
a day for or a for first step maybe a
for us before night be one with 92 c 4
it's really nice he really am is so
uncoordinated okay i can give this check
but it's not leading to much i think i
should just drop back here the bishop on
age six is now not having any useful
role it had prevented them i prevented
the castling check
okay take a five can take a five if I
can give this check all very nice i
think what i want to do is I want to get
the Queen involved too maybe to like
this should be six Queen III or
something I want I want the Queen here
on the queenside it's not well on g one
g for any more okay The Sharper be six
maybe I'm just what take I can just take
it
women night be 393 c5 is not defensible
black resigns they are just an opening
an opening disaster this line is very
well known to be to be very tricky for
black 95 what what black can do is so he
can he can take and after greenage h5
and play something like that this is all
with the bishop I mean it's both it both
quite quite nice for wide with the
bishop pair but ok this is still very
resilient you're not going to do this
quickly well while after that it is very
bad simply yeah just to show quickly
this is check totally disastrous yeah
mate it's already made checkmate quite
funny yeah and this is just check a
totally unplayable position even though
before was possible okay just just
developing stuff it's not bad he also
has absolutely no place for the king
enter on TM ABI should have quicker
getting the Queen over like here Queen
Queen here's probably better but Jack
it's it's just a matter of choosing a
way to win in a very favorable position
okay thanks for watching